we begin this morning with some major
breaking news on this Friday it actually
came just before 6 a.m. from Florida
where longtime Trump ally Roger stone
was arrested to face charges in Robert
Miller's Russia investigation he was
indicted just yesterday on seven counts
he's accused of lying to a congressional
committee and witness tampering
now stone had predicted that he would be
charged and he insisted he is innocent
Paula Reed looks at the indictment just
released this morning Paula good morning
good morning Gail I just finished
reading this 23 page indictment and the
special counsel has charged stone with
lying and obstruction of justice he is
expected to appear in court in Florida
in a short time but while this
indictment does not charge him with
conspiring or colluding with Russia it
lays out in great detail how he was in
contact with WikiLeaks as it released
stolen Democrat emails in the weeks
before the election these emails were
hacked by Russian intelligence and stone
came to the attention of investigators
with some tweets that he sent out that
suggested he knew some of these releases
were coming though he's always denied
that he had any insider information but
the most damaging information in this
indictment for the administration is
that stone was allegedly in touch with
Trump campaign officials about WikiLeaks
releases apparently he was talking about
timing when this would happen and these
Trump campaign officials were apparently
very interested to know about additional
releases now stones indictment it was
expected the special counsel has been
hearing from witnesses around him his
associates for months but it is a sign
that the special counsels investigation
is unlikely to wrap up anytime soon well
Roger stone Paulo certainly been very
loyal to president Trump but what does
this mean specifically for Donald Trump
well this is another problem for the
White House the president has repeatedly
denied that there was any contact
between his campaign and Russia he's
also denied that he had any business
interests in Russia during the campaign
but over the past few months so we've
gotten a lot of new evidence out of the
Special Counsel investigation
specifically his own lawyer has said
that in fact the president continued to
negotiate at least one business deal
well into the campaign we also now know
that his former Trump can
Payne chairman Paul Manafort was passing
polling data off to an associate with
known contacts to Russian intelligence
and now we have this new information
about Roger stone being in contact with
Trump campaign officials surrounding the
timing of these WikiLeaks releases so a
lot of new questions about whether or
not the president is being fully
truthful about how much he knew about
these contacts well thank you also
included in that indictment is the fact
that he tried to convince an other
witness to testify falsely in
conversations this should people should
be reminded that these WikiLeaks emails
disrupted the campaign throughout the
summer and until the election whipsawing
the news cycle at a precise and
important moments this is not some
sidelines this was important in the
middle of the camp the question has
always been about whether where there
was some collusion between the Trump
campaign and the Russian government in
order to disrupt the election and swing
it into the favor of Trump Roger stone
is accused essentially of being a
conduit for some of the information that
may have led to Hillary Clinton's defeat
as you point out that is not known
whether that was a factor but it is
known that as you point out it was
extremely disruptive the timeline is key
if you read this entire indictment it
goes through it's the summer of 2016
right through what were the conventions
right before heading up to the vote
that's why this is another giant piece
of the puzzle and the connection between
Russia and WikiLeaks is how do we
Keeley's get the underlying emails that
they then strategically leaked
throughout the campaign did they get
them from the Russians well we haven't
heard from the White House yet but
Donald Trump has repeatedly said no
collusion no collusion no collusion they
certainly seem to be connecting some
kind of dots here this morning which
you'll see